what is up guys welcome to the third
geographical plan within Python tutorial
where we left off we were drawing a map
like this bring it up and now what I
want to do is draw in country lines and
even state lines so what can we do for
that so it's actually really really easy
to do this and the let's change our fill
color for the continents to a bit
lighter so we can actually see what
we've done so I'll do 0 for BAE 3 and
then we'll keep the rest now just like
in draw coastlines you can also do em
die draw countries and now we'll plot
that real quick just to show you so now
you can see the countries have lines on
them and you can also do States if you
wanted so now you can say m dot draw
States and plot that so now you've got
countries and states pretty cool but
what if we want to make it really cool
so like I said in the last video I was
going to show you guys one really cool
projection that I happen to like there's
quite a few really high detailed
projections that you can make but my
favorite one is called Blue Marble so
let's go ahead and do that one or a
quick oh and actually before we get to
that sorry guys the other thing I want
to show you guys is you can also draw
rivers so let's get rid of will just
comment these out and MDOT draw rivers
well do well what you think it's going
to do and that's going to be draw rivers
so drag that over and so now all you see
is all the rivers which i think is
pretty cool so I don't have any use for
it personally but I think it looks cool
when you do it this clip anyway now to
the Blue Marble kind of left tantalizing
you guys so what you want to do is
is you can go MDOT blue marble and what
this is going to do is give you kind of
like almost like one of those like
satellite views right so it's not keeps
calling it a projection the projection
can change you can use this with any
projection what's actually changing is
the texture I suppose so anyway first
what we need to do is we need to comment
out well we'll stop drawing rivers
there's no reason to do that we don't
need to draw anything else I don't think
but we do need to close up the co
continents I don't want to do that and
the rest I think can just stay so once
you've done that rather that wait a
minute for it to pop up and here it is
check that out so now what we have is
kind of like a space view on most of
these continents so pretty cool if you
ask me you can zoom in pretty good it's
pretty high-quality image actually
considering that it's all free but
anyway that's pretty cool takes a long
time to load it up but if you do get it
to load its kind of cool to look at but
again we won't be using this there's a
couple others that you can do to you can
do like taupe typography and then
there's also like shaded relief and all
this stuff but not going to get into
that if you have that sounds interesting
to you guys you should check out the
basemap websites I've got all that stuff
on there but really my goal is to show
you guys how to plot stuff
geographically so we're going to get
there
so that's going to conclude this video
stay tuned to the next video as always
thanks for watching thanks for your
support subscription and until next time